Its been about a month since I got my shiny
new airPods 2 with wireless charging, I’ve
been using them almost every day, as a replacement
to the original airPods that I’ve owned
and loved since they were released over 3
years ago.
So what's the vedict, was it worth upgrading
and spending $200+ Tax?
To be honest, for me, no not really, but there
is one group of people who they do make sense
for, but I’ll cover that in a bit.
Coming up to launch of these new Airpods there
quite a bit of rumors.
Health tracking features, sweat resistance,
really fast wireless charging, and new colors.
None of that came true and a lot of people
were upset.
Airpods are everywhere and they had most people
love them, They even got a 98% customer satisfaction
rating which is really good.
It makes sense that people which is understandable
since over three years later we want some
of these great additions.
I personally would have loved getting them
in black.
What we got was some minor updates, wireless
charging if you spend $200, hey Siri support,
and a new H1 chip.
To be honest I wasn’t really interested
in wireless charging since I rarely have to
charge the case compared to a phone but it
was quite convient to just drop them onto
my qi pad when I get home instead of on my
nightstand, that way I never feel like I actually
have to change them.
With that said wireless charging is really
slow.
They accept 5 watts just like your standard
iPhone brick but take almost twice as long
to charge because wireless charging is less
efficient.
Them side by side and after 10min Airpods
2 only gained 8% wirelessly while my original
plugged in gained 20%.
I figured we wouldn’t get any sound improvements
since Apple didn't mention it and I was already
happy with the sound for an unsealed earbud.
One thing I was looking forward to is faster
and more reliable connections with the new
H1 chip and better range with BT5.
The H1 chip does connect noticeably faster
and slightly more reliably as well.
One issue I had in the past was swapping Airpods
from my iPhone to my Mac.
It would take a while and sometimes I would
have to hit connect another time.
Airpods 2 is faster and more reliable but
its not perfect, with that said even a month
later i’m often shocked how fast they can
connect.
We did a full comparison testing a bunch of
things between them, so if you want to check
out that detailed video you can click here
or the box after this video.
H1 also has less latency but its you can’t
notice it for music and videos since the iPhone
will wait to sync up, but this is noticeable
in games.
As for range, it's not really better any better.
Sometimes I leave my phone on the charger
playing podcasts or music while doing some
work outside.
If I get halfway down my driveway it cuts
out and same thing for most of my garage so
I was really hoping for some improvement.
Looking at Bluetooth 5 specs the range is
rated quite a bit longer but in my testing,
it was practically the same, well to specific
I got 3 feet further.
Last, let's touch on Hey Siri.
I’ve used it a few times when I didn’t
have my watch and it works quite well.
Delay is minimal and it's definitely better
than having to double tap to envoke siri.
If you don’t have an Apple watch and want
to have hands free control this could be a
legit reason to upgrade but personally for
me it's quicker just to spin my watch crown
to adjust volume or lift my wrist and ask
a question without having to say that special
phrase.
I mentioned one group of people that upgrading
to Airpods 2 make sense.
Those that bought Airpods close to launch
and have used them a lot since then.
I was surprised reading quite a bit of comment
from those saying the batteries in their originals
are now half of what they used to be, and
since they love them so much they have no
problems upgrading.
If you don’t need wireless charging, and
I would argue most dont you can refresh your
pair with a newer version thats faster, more
reliable, and with hey Siri for the same price
as before.
Actually possibly cheaper now that Amazon
officially sells them and has had a few sales
for $140, We’ll leave a link in the description.
So overall these small updates are an improvement
but for most people, unless your battery if
dead or you can really benefit from hey Siri,
upgrading to airpods 2 isn’t worth it.
Thank you guys for watching if you guys want
to see more videos like this one click the
card above to subscribe and check out our
airpods1 vs 2 detailed comparisons or are
Galaxy buds worth it for iPhone users.